[Musique]
avant une page santé avec mon nouvel
invité en parle d'abord de cette
nouvelle étape dans le département avec
les navettes autonome dans les yvelines
à une nouvelle étape pour le
développement de ses navettes la région
ile-de-france le groupe renault et
google ont annoncé vendredi dernier un
partenariat pour développer un réseau de
navettes autonome entre la rio à
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle et
la défense on en parle avec vous nicolas
d'ambri bonsoir bonsoir le risque de la
rédaction de tv 78 quels ont été les
détonateurs des annonces nicolas et bien
c'était vendredi dernier au technocentre
renault de guyancourt la président de la
région ile-de-france valérie pécresse et
à 10 ablis directeur business
développement de l'alliance renault
nissan mitsubishi ont annoncé leur
collaboration avec away mot c'est la
filiale de google
leur objectif développer une navette au
tonneau ne pour relier l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle au quartier de
la défense
et tout cela en passant par l'autoroute
l'un et l'a86 alors ce projet est prévu
pour quand et quels sont les raisons de
son développement l'idée serait de
mettre en place un service de transport
innovant à l'horizon 2024
vous y pensez c'est les jeux olympiques
aujourd'hui 1500 à 2000 personnes par
jour transitent entre ces deux sites
avec ses navettes autonome l'objectif
est de fluidifier le trafic et faciliter
le transit parce que cela se ferait
directement un projet financé à hauteur
de 100 millions d'euros par la région
ile-de-france écouter valérie pécresse à
ce sujet
la région va s'occuper des
infrastructures la région va s'occuper
des infrastructures c'est à dire des
routes pour les aménager y met des
capteurs permettre aussi avec l'état que
l'on puisse rouler sur les bandes
d'arrêt d'urgence est utilisé ces voies
supplémentaires pour faire des
expérimentations d'ici la mise en
service définitive en 2024
alors vous l'avez entendu assez les
bandes d'arrêt d'urgence qui seront
utilisés les bandes d'arrêt d'urgence de
l'a1 et de l'a86 concernant la navette
elle pourrait ressembler à ça les i go
un concept car de renault présenté au
salon de genève en 2018
une navette d'auto partage avec
plusieurs personnes à l'intérieur
la commande pourrait se faire via une
application on pense peut-être à vienne
à vigo un dispositif existant de la
région et un projet qui serait
développée notamment au technocentre
renault de guyancourt sur saint quentin
en yvelines
tous les concepts cars qui sont ici on a
comme l'a rappelé madame la présidente
on a beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle entre guillemets ici donc
on a des centres d'essai de simulation
donc c'est vraiment le lieu on peut
marier les différentes expertises
nécessaires pour pouvoir faire aboutir
ses concepteurs par contre ça
n'empêchera pas de faire des
expérimentations sur la route puisque
c'est là où l'acceptabilité et la
réalité des objets sera testée alors
voilà pour ce projet nicolas mais il y
en a bien d'autres dans les yvelines
effectivement grégory le véhicule
autonome dans les yvelines a commencé
autour d'une structure cvd comme créer
en 2012
cet institut de recherche développe ce
type de véhicule sur le plateau de
satory notamment ses deux navettes qui
circulent sur ce site depuis fin 2010 8
elle roule à 15 km heure maximum et sont
reliées à 16 satellites et fonctionne
avec des capteurs appelés les lidar 1-2
lidar sur le toit qui permettent de
détecter les bâtiments on va avoir un
lidar 3d ici un de chaque côté bien
entendu voilà qui permettent de docteur
de voir ce qui se passe sur les côtés et
enfin on va avoir des leaders en bas
4 donc et qui vont permettre notamment
de déclencher la chaîne de sécurité
c'est à dire que s'il ya une personne
qui arrive à navettes s'arrêtent autres
projets développés dans les yvelines
c'est tornados et à rambouillet le 8
octobre dernier des expérimentations été
réalisé avec deux véhicules autonomes
sur la voie publique un projet pour
développer un axe de véhicules autonomes
entre le centre commercial du bel air à
rambouillet et la gare de gaz rend un
projet lancé en 2014 et qui pourraient
aboutir autour de 2025 sur un axe dédié
et sur la route classique d'ici à 2030
merci nicolas pour ce point
d'information